today in the Forge we feel like doing a
little experiment we're going to ask you
to make blades using canister Damascus
but if you look around you notice
there's no canisters
that's because we're going to ask you to
use these
round tubes
we're calling this challenge tubular
canister now let's talk Steel
you each have a bucket of high carbon
steel in front of you we want you to use
every last ounce of it in your two inch
tubular canister good luck please miss
your time starts now my name is Ben
allenson I'm 34 years old I've been
bladesmithing about eight years now I
have a ton of people rooting for me back
home my wife and our four beautiful boys
and I just want to say my four beautiful
boys or dogs they're not people
I've never done a tubed Damascus before
step one make my canister clean up all
the material that's long so I don't get
sidetracked
it takes a while to cut a ball bearing
so I'm thinking it would be quicker to
draw it out and then just pretty much
throw the whole thing in a canister I'm
choosing not to use the white out
because I'm going to grind off that tube
when I'm done anyways well done I know
I'll have good high carbon steel on the
edge
I weld it up and threw it in the Forge
lo and behold no warps at all
I just need to grind some more to get
down to that good high carbon steel
my name is Kyle farays I'm 34 years old
I met my wife about a year and a half
ago and she introduced me to bladesmith
I think we actually forged our own
wedding rings
I got all these materials in front of me
I'm going to break them down as small as
I can fit them into that canister
I get the big ball bearing broken down
in the thirds I mean it's still not
fitting
so I've got to take more pieces off of
it normally you'd use a square can so
when you're putting it through the press
to forge weld you got your dies set up
so if you would get nice even pressure
whereas with a tube you're not going to
get nice even pressure I'm going to work
it slow like I'm packing a snowball you
know if you pack a snowball real slow
you're going to get it nice and hard
okay Kyle just quenched nice
I take it out of the Quench and it's
like I'm looking out a banana so I try
and straighten it out by applying some
pressure on it with all that mild steel
jacketing that blade he actually can
bend it quite a bit
my name is Zach Tarbell I'm 27 years old
I'm from Rochester New York I'm a
welding instructor and a part-time
bladesmith
I'm ready to go to work and I'm looking
for a challenge my plan for the canister
is to cut off six inches which is going
to be easier to manage in and out of the
forge and on the power hammer
looking out how much tube you need
I believe at least a half inch of
material on either side of what I wanted
so I've got sacrificial material to get
rid of
a round canister is an unknown to me I
don't know how it's going to behave I'm
used to square tube
so I decide to start with something that
I'm familiar with Zach squared up this
pipe
we always use squaring
up equally on all four faces to compress
to the center and we don't have any
rounding dies
so I'm trying to fit everything in the
canister it's just not fitting I dump
everything out try to redo it I'm not
gonna have room but my canisters just
too small
okay same as Zach is having trouble
fitting some of those larger chunks of
metal into his tube well he's invested a
bunch of time in squaring up that tube
so might as well stick with the
investment
so that it hits me why don't I just make
the canister bigger
so I'm gonna make a new piece of square
tube cutting a little piece off of it
and weld everything together this is a
faster solution than starting over nice
question
it looks good it feels good
five four three two one put down your
work this round is over
all right guys congratulations the three
of you will be moving forward into round
two of the competition in this round I
want you guys to add handles to your
blades you'll see on your workstations
you each have six pieces of round stock
I want you to use those to make spiraled
fluted handles
good luck please miss your time starts
now so my plan is to tackle the handle
first
Ben's doing the throw it at the floor
test there you go is you checking the
strength of them yeah some of this stuff
can be really brittle if anything
blatantly shatters I shouldn't use that
if it does yeah
Ben's the first one on the grinder
putting his flutes in oh it's horrible
the flutes that I just put in are not
gonna work it just doesn't feel good in
my hand it's way too big he put the
fluting in before he started shaping his
handle so isn't he just gonna lose the
fluting yeah I need to take more
material off of this handle first you're
gonna have to go back and do it again
yep she just took 30 minutes and chucked
them out the window I need to stop doing
this because it's sucking up too much
time I want to just get the handle
shaped and then I'll take the Dremel and
put flutes in smaller by hand
I was looking through well he went with
brass I know I want to use brass to make
a garden a pommel to add a little bit of
counterweight for such a large blade
if I take it over the bandsaw and no
issues getting through it
I decide to put my handle on first
remove a ton of material get the basic
shape of my handle done
I'm holding onto this thing and I'm I'm
thinking about what my wife told me make
sure you make it so it fits everybody
else's hand and not just yours and then
I look over at Ben Abbott and I'm like
this guy's got tiny little hands I hope
this thing fits in his hand
a little concerned about that clock two
hours is pretty short to make a hidden
tang with a flute
has that polluted anything no
right now I'm feeling confident in the
time that I have and the amount that I
have to get done on this knife the last
thing that I want is to go home on
account of an uncomfortable handle I
want to spend the last five minutes
working on my Edge I know that this is
cutting it close but I'm pretty sure
that I can do it five minutes remaining
you can throw flutes on a blade in in a
minute if you've done it before
I'm pleased with what I have in front of
me I can't believe that I've pulled off
that handle in two hours
and then I take a look at the blade in
my left and my right
my heart sinks
I've forgotten to put those flutes on
the handle
to test the strength and overall
durability of your blades I'll be
chopping into these steel wind chimes
now this is not about what your blades
do to those wind chimes it's about what
those wind chimes through the edge of
your blade
Ben you're up first you ready for this
yes sir
I'm a little concerned about my Edge I
just hope that the Chimes aren't too big
of a deal and my knife doesn't snap or
something like that
thank you
been a lot of the weight still in this
blade from when we evaluated it didn't
get much lighter as a matter of fact
adding that guard probably added more
weight and there's not a lot of
counterbalance as far as hitting the
pipes go you can see that there are some
rolled over sections packed out sections
and certainly sections where you've lost
your Edge but it's solid one piece good
job cool thanks all right Kyle you're up
next you ready oh yeah good
I'm a little bit nervous about my Edge I
designed it more for the sharpness test
as opposed to the strength test I hope
when Dave's done hitting these wind
chimes my blade is in one piece
[Music]
okay cow first off hold up your hand
yeah I figured you got some big mitts
man that's a big handle I don't know I
don't think they're that big
as far as how your blade did you've got
plenty of edge still left on this blade
but you can see here we've got a lot of
rolling but there's still a lot of Edge
on this knife it's a good job awesome
thanks Dave you bet all right Zach
you ready yes sir okay
I don't know what the judges are going
to say
if not for that one parameter I believe
that my knife would do well through the
strength and sharpness test
hopefully they're going to decide to
test it
I know in the back of my head I don't
have those flutes
the Flutie
you can see all the way around
you guys all agree
Zach we asked you guys to give us a
fluted handle but your knife does not
have that
it was a pleasure watching you in round
one unfortunately your knife does not
meet parameters so for that reason we've
got to ask you to leave the fourth floor
thanks for coming out man thank you
I agree with the judges the right call I
missed a parameter the other guys didn't
this time around I realized I may not
have brought my a game if I get a second
chance
I'm bringing it